they say pizza i say yes whoa spaghettio
all right jackson asked to make pretzels
and the trailer yes sour
pizza it was truly one of the most
beautiful days
we've had in a very long time
[Music]
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okay mom
and i have been
really boring and tired this past year
it's true i've been very overwhelmed
i've been on autopilot
and i've been really tired and so i want
to kind of reinvigorate the
fun in our family i'm bringing back an
old
video a very long time ago i only said
yes to my kids for a week
at the time they were very young and i
want to see what it looks like
now that they're older so for one week
i'm going to only say yes to my kids to
everything they ask for
wish me luck so here's the plan i really
don't want them to catch on to this
because i don't want their requests to
snowball and escalate into something i
can't do
but my hope is that it creates some fun
memorable moments for us and also
new ways for us to bond together the
rules pretty much stay the same as the
last time we did this it's got to be a
secret they can't find out that i'm
doing this
we gotta keep it clean they have to
bathe they have to brush their teeth
they have to do personal hygiene
but the little addition this time around
is it has to be pandemic friendly we
can't be planning things that aren't
safe we're taking our
walk our usual neighborhood walk whoa
it almost hit me the first thing the
boys asked for was surprisingly easy
which i was not expecting
they asked if we could take our
neighborhood walk that we like to take
nice
of course the first thing they ask for
isn't crazy because they have no idea
what's going on
so i really should have known that it
would have been an
average day for that first day of me
trying this
so here's hoping it'll stay this way for
the rest of the week
it really didn't take long for the weird
food requests to start coming in
spaghetti you want spaghettios for lunch
at 10 30. okay
so good go ahead
wyatt has always been really difficult
at meal time he doesn't like sitting
down for meals
he doesn't like finishing all the food
on his plate
so this actually clued me into maybe
his hunger pattern is a little bit
different than my meal schedule
and i might need to adjust a little bit
for him to make sure that
he's eating enough and also enjoying his
food
as a parent i'm always learning and so
that taught me
a little bit more about quiet jackson
asked to make fries
pretzels homemade soft pretzels today i
would have never
said yes to this they take forever to
make but i had to say yes
what do we have here jackson uh we have
yeast
sugar salt and water and then what do we
have here
flour yep our dough is coming together
give it a slap like this there we go
this is a little fat boy pretzel
go what look i do this
give it a try careful not to drop it
look at that this stick boy oh my gosh
i did not feel like making these at all
i'm so glad we did they smell
fantastic
they were all fluffy amazing
do you guys do a good job what do you
want henry
[Music]
even henry gets yes
are you happy now mama baby grandpa
yep by day three i'm pretty sure the
boys were catching on because they
asked me for something i would never
agree to do all right what did you ask
me to make
i asked you to make a yummy candy
plattered
candy platter all right let's get
started
i love candy tik tok so there are all
these amazing candy shops
on tick tock with these cool candies
that
just look so fun to eat and so the kids
will sometimes scroll through and watch
with me
so they finally asked if we could get
some
and make a whole candy platter of all
these crazy candies
it's a hundred percent my fault i'm
showing them
videos of awesome looking candy and then
expecting that they're not gonna want it
yeah right
so i should have known better but
secretly
i wanted an excuse to try it too
try our magic potion
cotton candy mmm tastes just like dr
pepper
weird flaps are cool because you can
just make your own
shaped lollipops
we had a nice long teeth brushing
session
after all that sugar and they were over
the top hyper
the rest of the day i really couldn't
tell if they were on to me
i don't think they fully realized that i
was only saying yes wyatt has
made a dinner request
what did you ask for glass pizza
grassroots pizza
wait with real grass now i would go out
and find some grass except the fact that
i live in the desert
and there's literally no grass anywhere
out here
so that's off the table i'm gonna have
to get really creative about
something edible that also looks like
grass i have my grass
basil and cilantro
grass kinda
grass pizza enjoy grass
jackson liked it jackson likes
everything he's
easy and then you know matt coming in
clutch with
so good all right
oh hi honey you want some
[Music]
you like it
so jackson asked where are we sleeping
tonight
and the trailer in the trailer one
weekend when i was gone with the kids
matt went and bought a travel trailer
here's ziggy
i wanna win for so long i just think
they're so
fun and portable and cute and
so multifunctional that i've i've really
wanted one forever we named it ziggy
because it has the cute little lightning
bolt
and it's just perfect so when jackson
requested that we all sleep in the
trailer together i got very excited
because
it would be my first time okay here we
are
in ziggy the trailer the boys initially
wanted all of us to sleep in there
but henry really couldn't sleep in there
there was no room for all of us
so matt stayed in the house with henry
and i stayed in the trailer with the
older boys
welcome to the trailer
i forget how fun it is for all of us to
play cards together
[Music]
before
you happy to be in here i forgot to wash
my face
but too bad
did you brush your teeth did wyatt
i don't think so oh geez oh my god
well he's out he's asleep
all right good night everybody good
night
[Applause]
how did you sleep how'd you sleep
what how'd you sleep i'm watching
big time rush i slept
terribly because i
having a baby i wake up anytime someone
startles
because i just get up with a baby in the
night and i was sleeping between two of
the most restless sleepers of all time
so every time they moved i'd wake up
i want my decaf caramel macchiato with
my little breakfast sandwich with uh
some bacon in it
yeah i want my decaf caramel macchiato
oh my gosh
that tastes good a lot of you have
noticed in the last few episodes that
wyatt really enjoys this one pair of elf
pajamas so
this week i couldn't make him change i
couldn't say no
he wore his elf pajamas to his heart's
content
and we just went with it as the week
progressed the boys
really wanted to get out of the house so
they asked if we could go to pioneer
town which is
pretty close to where we live but it is
really
the spot you want to go to if you want
to do something outdoors that feels very
safe
and isn't super crowded because it's a
lot of wide open spaces
you're hungry
are you hungry for chips yes
[Music]
lemonade are you guys enjoying
yourselves
oh wait henry oh my goodness
jackson also asked if we could take a
walk wyatt didn't want to go and jackson
said
good because i want it to just be you
and me and so i
happily obliged what are we talking
about we're going to talk about some
minecraft mods
minecraft yes it's hot
[Music]
we can take our masks down for a second
because nobody is around
i like our time together
this is my buddy barbecue yeah
yeah yeah do you want a barbecue or do
you want us to order barbecue
[Music]
you want a barbecue yeah all right it
was nice that jackson asked to take the
walk
because that's pretty much all we can do
one on one right now
and if he's happy to do that i'm happy
to deal with him
the final day i knew something big was
coming i just
didn't have any clue what it would be
where did we go jackson that was so cool
we're at the beach we went to the beach
oh the beach
we haven't gone to the beach in the
longest time
going to the beach is a lot of work when
you have kids but this time i couldn't
say no
so to the beach we went wait what you
doing
are we gonna build a sandcastle it's a
beautiful day
it's so nice out and we brought
some sandwiches and it's gonna be
amazing
i'm having the best day ever
the boys loved the beach so much it was
truly one of the most beautiful days
we've had in a very long time
the boys asked for pizza for dinner i'm
on board with us
i'm excited they say pizza i say yes
when we went to pizza henry got his
first official
slice of pizza
while i was saying yes to the boys this
week it really opened my eyes to the
fact that my
mood sets the tone for the day and if
i'm taking care of myself and taking
care of my mental health
i'm setting the tone for the rest of my
family
it really reminded me that my kids needs
at the end of the day their core needs
are very simple
it's not this like wild grand gesture
that makes them happy
there are also all of these small
moments that also make them happy
so that's all for now let me know on
instagram what you thought of this video
if you have any more fun ideas for us to
try
while we're still together if you'll
please excuse us
uh we got a lot of games going a lot of
activities going who's this
your western friend tom tom
catboy till next time bye
bye why you want to say bye
[Music]
you